[Music]
so george the scams are up i'm seeing on
this article that our producer james
handed us
on the uh
dad blame student loans the federal
trade commission's warning about an
increase in these scams yeah this is bad
and uh of course they're preying on
people's confusion and people are
getting stressed about student loan
pause being unpaused and so they're
saying the federal government put
federal student loan payments on pause
during the pandemic with that pause
expiring people are anxious and the
scammers are swooping in they're
promising to reduce payments or even
cancel student debt entirely
if you give them your credit card number
they use social media text messages
phone calls and the scripts are
convincing some of them even sound like
they're coming from this hi this is shea
with sla servicing we're in the process
of pre-enrollment for all loan
forgiveness it's going to be a bit more
challenging as deadlines come and so
we'll need your credit card to be able
to get this you'd be a great scammer
dave i'll tell you what this is for the
radio voice on to do that right there we
go
so this is so scummy so i want to give
people some quick tips and tools to
avoid getting scammed number one if a
student loan servicer calls you it's
probably a scam
generally these they don't work that
hard they're not calling you they've got
better things to do so some red flags
you got to look out for if they're
asking you for your username and
password if they're asking you for
banking information if you've already
given your payment information call your
bank put a hold on that account
immediately so they can't get any more
money you can report all this stuff to
the federal trade commission the uh the
consumer financial protection bureau
your state attorney general
don't fall for this stuff yeah
let me just tell you it's a good rule
here's a basic thing on scam avoidance
and you've done a lot of this stuff on
fine print
if someone that you already are doing
business with like you have a student
loan
you have a credit card you shouldn't but
you have a debit card you have a credit
card you have a
you you have an irs account and they
call you up and say this is joe with the
irs to verify that we're talking with
the right person would you please give
us your social security number the irs
never does that
they already have your social security
number they don't need to ask you
your bank does not we need to verify
would you give us your your uh your
credit card number
no
i won't you should already have that if
i already am doing business with you
know we need your we need to verify your
bank information and we're with uh sally
mae
no you should probably already have my
bank information and so they'll never
ask that kind of stuff so this just this
should the red flag should go off the
siren should go off the b p p people
ought to be going off when you hear that
i just don't answer phone calls these
days they're usually no good but here's
what you can do i got a call from russia
tell me about my stoop my extended
warranty the car's extended warranty
dave yeah i don't think they're worried
about that right now they got bigger
problems but here's the thing
russia oh yeah on my phone i got that
too are we getting the same call yeah
wow well here's a good rule of thumb a
lot of these places can spoof the exact
number they can spoof the sheriff's
office they can spoof the irs number so
even if you get a call and it says it's
the same number as the irs go to the irs
website check the phone number and you
call them back
because that way you avoid running into
that situation and so like
we had a a couple of people on get
scammed or almost get scammed or
whatever here
uh that was a call from the local
sheriff's department and when you called
their number back that they left
it was the exact recording they had
taken a recording from the sheriff's
department and put it over there with
the same phone tree and everything yeah
but if you call the sheriff's department
they would say oh no there's a scam
going around don't talk to those people
don't go over there and pay parking fees
that you don't know don't go over there
and you know there's not an arrest
warrant out for you you know that kind
of stuff so you gotta you gotta hang up
and call back
directly not the number the scammer
gives you but the actual number that you
have
and then you'll find out oh that really
wasn't a real person that was shay is in
somewhere
in some slavic company country or
whatever oh my gosh yeah don't fall for
this stuff guys and i know people are
stressed and when you're stressed it can
get you to be panicked and you start
making poor decisions well
there's two times people get scammed
okay
when you're afraid and desperate and
when you're greedy
like if you think you're gonna get
something free and easy
people fall for that one too
and so student loan forgiveness is the
free and easy thing
yeah they go oh well forgive your
student loans but you need to send us
two hundred dollars to verify yeah
that's not or just i just need your
credit card number so we can get the
account set up to get this going and i'm
like well if you're going to forgive it
why do you need the number
and yeah if it seems too good to be true
it's too it is don't do it yeah
there you go good stuff that's happening
it's happening out there right this
second and it usually comes with irs
stuff or the other ones that come up are
people collecting uh money for charities
for um war-torn countries and all kinds
of stuff yeah it's a problem